Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
l'effet Doppler.
Imaginons deux personnes.
Appelons les A et B.
A se met à crier.
En criant, elle émet une onde qui se propage
dans l'air avec une certaine fréquence.
Si la fréquence est élevée,
le son va être aigu.
Si la fréquence est faible,
le son va être grave.
B, qui se trouve à une certaine distance
de A, entend le son produit, car il reçoit
les ondes sonores, avec la même fréquence.
Maintenant, observons ce qui se passe si A
se rapproche de B.
On voit que les ondes devant A s'écrasent.
Ceci implique que leur fréquence augmente,
car la distance entre deux ondes diminue.
De l'autre côté les ondes s'étirent.
Ainsi leur fréquence diminue, car la distance
entre deux ondes augmente.
Comme la fréquence à droite a augmenté,
B va entendre des ondes sonores plus aiguës.
Et si B se trouvait de l'autre côté, comme
la fréquence à gauche a diminué, alors
B entendrait des ondes sonores plus graves.
C'est ça qu'on appelle l'effet Doppler.
Pour résumer, si un objet émet une onde
avec une certaine fréquence, et qu'il se
rapproche du récepteur, alors le récepteur
recevra l'onde avec une fréquence plus élevée.
Et à l'inverse, si l'émetteur s'éloigne
du récepteur, alors le récepteur recevra
l'onde avec une fréquence moins élevée.
Un bon exemple de l'effet Doppler est le déplacement
d'une voiture.
Lorsque la voiture se rapproche de nous, on
entend une note aiguë, et lorsqu'elle s'éloigne
une note plus grave.
D'une manière plus générale, l'effet Doppler
ne s'applique pas qu'au son, il s'applique
à toutes les ondes.
C'est pour ça que lorsqu'une galaxie s'éloigne,
on la voit légèrement plus rouge, et lorsqu'elle
se rapproche, légèrement plus bleue.